they found us
we need to go on the one hand mosquito
coast is a straight-up pure adventure
story
about a family that is on the run and
needs to
get to a destination to gain safety for
themselves and their family
but the other story is a very determined
man manipulating his family
to do things that they wouldn't normally
want to do or need to do
leaving where america why this family
has secrets
and has problems financial and emotional
and otherwise
but instead of leaning further into that
family drama
we exploded
whatever they did in their past they're
individuals who raged against the
machine and now
they're people who are on the run from
the law i think they're doing everything
to find
a new civilization that's going to save
them and give them the normal life that
they have been dreaming of
you need to tell the kids they could get
hurt it'll be an education
ally fox he's an incredibly bright man
he's
pursuing his own desires and not
necessarily his families
it's sort of a fine line between doing
what's right for your family and then
being emotionally manipulative to get
what you want
ally we're really in trouble we just
make the move
and we start again you look at these
people that think they're the perfect
parents and then doing the right thing
to give their children a better life
they're totally isolated from the rest
of the world
no internet no technology at all and
just like
living as their own tribe island
basically han solo
from the movie we don't really watch
movies or tv
shows mostly just read books and stuff
dina has been homeschooled her only
friends are her parents and her brother
she's really looking for just structure
because
that's anything that she has yet to have
i think by exposing this family to the
kind of the furnace of experience
we begin revealing to the viewer
and to each other their true nature
you're better off with your mother and i
in
what world do you know how deranged you
sound
how you deal with that situation how you
respond to it both externally and
internally i think makes for really good
storytelling
there's just something compelling about
this very thrilling ride that they're on
trust me we'll be fine
you